-A whistle-blower
has reportedly claimed
that President Trump
made a troubling promise
to a foreign leader.
for more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yesterday the President
flew to San Diego
to visit a section of his dumb
border wall which was reportedly
just a replacement
reinforcement barrier
erected in an area where smaller
barriers had already existed.
And, as usual,
Trump was impressed
with the stupidest details
like the fact that the wall
was supposedly super hot.
-It's designed to absorb heat,
so it's extremely hot.
The wall is --
you won't be able to touch it.
You can -- You can
fry an egg on that wall.
[ Light laughter ]
-You can fry an egg
on a wall?
[ Laughter ]
I know there are a lot of things
he doesn't understand,
but I didn't think
gravity was on that list.
Did he see --
[ Laughter and applause ]
Do you think he saw
a Salvador Dalí painting
and think it was a cookbook?
[ Light laughter ]
"You can fry an egg
on that wall,
and you can melt a clock
on that tree."
[laughter and applause]
I know the expression,
"So hot you can
fry an egg on it,"
but I've never heard it
said about a wall.
Everything with this guy
is an infomercial.
"You heard of a frying pan.
Well, now we're introducing
the frying wall."
[laughter and applause]
Trump also tried to tout what
he claimed was new technology
that would allow the government
to track people
trying to cross the border,
but an official who was with him
on the trip
tried to warn him against
saying anything about it.
-One thing we haven't
mentioned is technology.
They're wired
so that we will know
if somebody's trying
to break through
and you may want to discuss
that a little bit, General.
-Sir, there could be some
merit in not discussing that.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
I like that.
That was a great answer.
-Yeah.
-I'll just tell you
they're wired.
-My God.
This guy is supposed to be
the Commander in Chief.
Could you imagine his fireside
chats during World War II?
"We'll be launching a top-secret
offensive against the Germans
in an undisclosed location.
General Eisenhower,
do you want to tell everyone
more about Normandy?
[ Laughter and applause ]
You're shaking your head no.
You were saying
it was a beach in France.
Is that right?"
Now, Trump has gone to extreme
and possibly even illegal
lengths to get this wall.
For one thing, he's moved
hundreds of millions of dollars
from programs like FEMA,
military schools, and daycare
to pay for border enforcement
and construction of the wall.
And on top of that,
he's so desperate
to get the wall done
before the 2020 election,
he's actually promised pardons
to officials who have to break
the law to get it done.
-President Trump promised
his supporters a border wall
and he plans to give it
to them by 2020.
According to
the "Washington Post,"
the President
has directed aides
to fast track
billions of dollars worth
of construction contracts,
aggressively seize private land,
and disregard
environmental rules.
And according
to the reporting --
this is coming right
out of the "Washington Post" --
he also told
worried subordinates
that he will pardon them
of any potential wrongdoing
should they have to break laws
to get the barriers
built quickly.
-He promised to pardon them.
But, of course, the unspoken
promise
is he will forget
he ever said that.
"Hey, I did what you said.
Can I get that pardon?"
"I'd love to help you,
I'm very busy.
I'm trying to get this God damn
egg to stick to the wall."
[ Laughter ]
Trump is openly
flouting the law
by dangling pardons
for illegal behavior,
and, of course,
this isn't the first time
he's just openly defied
legal requirements
like subpoenas from Congress.
In fact, at this very moment,
his administration
is refusing to give Congress
a secret whistle-blower
complaint
from within
the intelligence community.
Now, we don't know exactly
what's in the complaint,
but last night,
the "Washington Post"
reported something stunning.
It has to do with
the President himself
making a reportedly troubling
promise to a foreign leader.
-The story that is rocking
Washington this morning.
A communication between
President Trump
and a foreign leader prompting
a whistle-blower complaint.
-Former US intelligence official
familiar with the matter
told NBC News President Trump
spoke by phone
to a world leader over
the summer and made a promise.
We do not know
what the promise was.
who the foreign leader is.
-President Trump's interaction
with the foreign leader
included a promise that
was regarded was so troubling
that it prompted an official
in the US intelligence community
to file a formal
whistle-blower complaint
with the inspector general
for the intelligence community.
-That's right.
Trump reportedly promised
something so troubling
an intelligence official filed
a whistle-blower complaint.
Now, we don't know which foreign
leader this is,
and this is a
complicated story.
so just to help you
follow along,
we put together a helpful
little mnemonic device.
Remember, it's a promise
from the United States,
made by Trump to an
international leader,
but we do not know
their name.
Could be anyone.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And I -- I for one
am just shocked
this is the first whistle-blower
complaint Trump has had.
The way this guy behaves,
there should be literal
whistle-blowers
following him
everywhere he goes.
-We're dealing
with a Democrat--
[ Whistles blaring ]
-Now today,
Trump responded to this report,
not by insisting he would
never do such a thing,
but claiming that he was
too smart to do such a thing.
Here's the first part
of his tweet.
"Another fake news story
out there, it never ends."
Virtually, any time I speak on
the phone to a foreign leader,
I understand that there
may be many people listening
from various US agencies.
Not to mention those
from the other country, itself.
No problem."
Why does he end his tweet like
we asked him for a favor?
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, Donald, can you hop on
this car with a foreign leader
and also drop us off
at the airport?"
"No problem, what terminal?"
Trump then continued in his
second tweet writing,
"Is anybody dumb enough
to believe
that I would say something
inappropriate
with a foreign leader
while on such a potentially
heavily-populated call?"
It's not the we're dumb enough
to believe it.
It's that we're smart enough
to believe
you're dumb enough to do it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
So Trump is dangling pardons
for illegal behavior.
He's making shocking promises
to foreign leaders.
He probably feels like he has
impunity to do whatever he wants
because so far he's faced
almost no consequences.
I mean, remember the Mueller
report?
It was full of incredibly
damning evidence
about the President
welcoming and encouraging
the help of a foreign
government,
his financial ties
to that government,
and his attempts
to obstruct the investigation.
That report came out in April,
more than five months ago,
and in the meantime,
Democratic leaders
have been arguing
over whether to move forward
with impeachment.
In fact, they can't even
seem to agree
on the words they should use.
-The House Judiciary Committee
just this morning
approved new ground rules
for its impeachment inquiry
or investigation or both.
-Some call this process
an impeachment inquiry.
Some call it
an impeachment investigation.
There's no legal difference
between these terms,
and I no longer care
to argue about nomenclature.
-But it seems
other House Leaders
do still care
about the nomenclature,
with the House Speaker
still refusing to say
that the House has launched
such an investigation.
-Is the specific language
not important?
I mean, how should the American
people understand the work...
-The American people
will understand --
-...when members are speaking
very differently about it.
-Impeachment is a very
divisive measure,
but if we have to go there,
we'll have to go there.
But we can't go there
unless we have the facts.
-What do you mean unless
you have the facts?
you have the facts.
Robert Mueller wrote
a 448-page report,
and I assure you,
there are lots of facts in it.
Robert Mueller can't write a
text message to his wife
without facts in it.
"Should be home in half an hour.
Pursuant to all applicable
Federal Regulations
governing the operation
of automobiles
under jurisdiction
of Federal Code 23-C,
subsection 19
regarding speed limits
and the use of signaling devices
to conduct lane changes
and assuming the availability
of premium-grade fuel
that meets or supersedes
all relevant State and Federal
Efficiency standards,
smiley face, heart emoji."
[ Laughter and applause ]
In fact, House Speaker --
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
has apparently been so resistant
to attempts by other Democrats
to move forward with impeachment
in the Judiciary Committee
led by Jerry Nadler
that she slammed them
in a private meeting last week
and then specifically told them
to leak that private meeting
to the press.
-House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
sending a loud message
to her Judiciary Committee
chairman.
Pull back on impeachment.
"You can feel free
to leak this."
That's what Pelosi told
lawmakers in a meeting last week
according to multiple people
who spoke to POLITICO.
"This" refers to the Speaker's
displeasure at Jerry Nadler
and his Judiciary Committee
staff.
In that meeting, Pelosi
complained Nadler and his staff
keep talking about impeachment
as the likely result
of their investigations,
which she sees as putting the
party at risk for a 2020 defeat.
-Damn, she actually told them,
"You can feel free
to leak this."
it's like if your teacher caught
you passing notes in class
and said, "do you mind
if I read this out loud?"
and you said, "Sure,"
and the note said, "You suck.
Thanks for reading this
out loud."
[ Laughter ]
And yet, in spite of Pelosi's
reluctance, on Tuesday,
we got even more damning
evidence of Trump's lawlessness
when House Democrats grilled
his former campaign manager,
Corey Lewandowski.
Now, Tuesday's hearing was
weird to say the least
because Lewandowski
is a prolific liar.
When it comes to lying,
Lewandowski even gives
Trump a run for his money.
When these two talk,
it must be Lie-A-Palooza.
"Looking trim, Mr. President."
"Thank you, Corey,
and may I say,
you don't look anything
like a psychopath.
[ Laughter ]
Definitely don't look like
you're gonna do deck somebody."
And on top of that,
Trump's White House
invoked executive privilege
over his communications
with Lewandowski,
which is insane,
because Lewandowski
never worked in the White House,
let alone the Executive Branch,
and yet Lewandowski
insisted on stonewalling,
which resulted
in exchanges like these.
-Did you ever suggest
to the President or anyone else
that you thought your
communications with him
were official
White House communications?
-Congressman,
the White House has directed
I not disclose the substance
of any discussions with
the President or his advisers
to protect Executive Branch
confidentiality.
-How many times
has the President asked you
to meet him in the White House?
-The White House has directed
I not disclose
the substance of any--
-How many times did he direct
you to deliver a message
to a member of his cabinet?
-The White House has directed
I not disclose
the substance of any discussions
with the President.
-Did he ever discuss with you
any concerns
that he may have committed
a criminal offense?
-The White House has directed
I not disclose the substance
of any discussions with
the President or his advisers.
-Has the president ever
offered you a pardon?
-Again, the White House
has directed I not disclose
the substance of any discussions
with the President
or his advisers
to protect Executive Branch
confidentiality.
-Wow, he won't say whether
Trump offered him a pardon not.
Man, his seat is so hot,
you could fry an egg on it.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, once you turned it
sideways.
Now, whether it's withholding
whistle-blower complaints
from Congress or dangling
pardons to cover up crimes,
Trump is a lawless President
acting like a guy
who thinks he can get away
with whatever he wants.
There's at least one way
to show him he's wrong,
and that's impeachment,
but some Democratic leaders
are afraid to even touch the
subject
because they think it's...
-Extremely hot.
-This has been "A Closer Look."